yeah welcome to this game fighting
dragon I don't want the dragon fighting
dragons got a name n de cristian kupka
yeah there are many international
masters in Germany don't even know this
guy I probably heard the name last but
ok um yeah let's play this age 39 again
I recently won against the John none
with the exchange so let's see if this
guy what this guy is doing yeah I see it
since that time he knows this sliding
roof you don't know the ideas to play c5
yeah I'm threatening c5 like now I'm gap
this is so one of the moves that I can
play yeah wyd is starting and only
attack on the queenside should a six and
if it takes on d5 now I go to d3 this is
an interesting position where Y term has
given up the the bishops but Haslem
advanced pants on before NC 5
well it's interesting i'm also of course
just threatening on d5 what is blacks
move here why am i confusing something
I'm not sure something similar like that
is at least a theoretical line I think
he needs to retreat you look a Tandy
seven or something if I take on d5 this
you for winning a piece mmm yeah yeah
this this is right I think black needs
to drop the look back if he takes Bishop
takes it's not so easy to make a move
defies yep just just bad for strategical
reasons I have most others the idea
Bishop to c4 night to d3 and I'm just
excellent down in specials don't do do
anything good Saudi for you can
immediately dismiss and probably will
play that and all that I say you can
dismiss it immediately yeah here we go
yeah okay if you don't spot rook e8 the
idea then you probably think you you
need to do that yeah okay it's not like
a white is winning four or so it's just
them a nice position with the night on
d3 it coordinates very nicely
only for you five probably or should I
play p fire behaves for the pattern I
don't want that Roxy one and then c6
should be a should do nice are
interesting interesting yeah be six
maybe even be six answer could could be
an idea or just adjust c6 breaking
breaking through this is probably not
the best c6
okay maybe maybe still stole this still
very one-sided to that position my dears
that I have f4 later over the pond hmm
don't think that capture with the porn
is so dangerous when I want him to play
rugby aight to get passive with this
look yeah I know F for justice i was
there damn if he takes my take the night
will get to d5 and this is not not
bearable for black and i really don't
see a move now yeah this is nice nicely
dominating this position it so it's
almost alone i can just pick pick up
everything jack
ok so now let's look for the best way to
convert probably here just spinning and
now there are some multiple threads just
in seven for instance yeah okay keep it
to keep it simple he needs to take now
and then the bee pollen promotes okay
jack okay it still promotes yeah the
song was a nice display that the
exchange is not such a bad line in this
circle crete position I think he really
needs to to drop the route back if i'm
remembering this correctly it was quite
some years that i had a look at this I
think he needs to to drop back here
maybe to e7 may be here yeah now if I
take his goatee form and this is tricky
but interesting i think wider white can
go here now f5s an idea this kind of
position can be can be interesting with
these things to come in the game this d
4 is just a very one-sided position with
the night ii m it's just yeah a three
against two this pawn is located by the
night
and black has no no active play
whatsoever so very difficult to defend
our thing yeah thanks for watching